are you here I'm always after the fight
you hear Habib say alhamdulillah excuse
me guys he sees hobbies cousin so Conor
takes a swing and hits him and digs
escalade and they're chanting something
took beer Allahu Akbar stop beer you
know I believe he threw his back out god
is great
yes they can greed is a piece how you
guys doing welcome to the deed show I'm
excited that you're with me and hope
you're excited to be here we got an
exciting guest it's going to be very
exciting as it is subscribe right now if
you haven't hit that notification bell
we got Xavier Mendes one of the top
trainers in the world he's got several
UFC fighters that he trains two of them
that you might know Daniel Cormier just
had his match last week and our brother
Habib
this is Habib's coach Habib's trainer
along with his father but he takes care
of him when he's here in the US and I'm
hamdullah he's here in the D show we're
gonna be talking about many things how
you can if you're running a successful
gym or you want to some of the top three
tips he's gonna be giving us he's gonna
talk about some of the mistakes he's
made and how you can learn from his
mistakes and not making those mistakes
how important nutrition is in training
we're gonna be talking about some of the
commotion that happened with hubby Eve
and Connor in his fight and it's going
to get even more exciting because we're
gonna have a exciting quiz call it the
Xavier Mendes quiz all that and more on
this week's episode of the D show
[Music]
[Music]
of your Mendez how are you how you doing
I'm doing good thank you for being with
us here on the Dean show thanks for
having me on board
Javier Mendez let's take you back a
little bit you're at the aka gym and you
got 100 plus minus young guys coming to
see Habib and they've surrounded you
guys you're up against the wall and
they're chanting something took B it
Allah Akbar beer you've probably never
heard this maybe you have you don't know
what it means
the excitement is amazing what are you
feeling what are you thinking you know I
was very happy to see so many people
come and support Habib and and and the
love they had for him and the energy it
was pretty amazing to be honest with you
that's what was going through my mind
it's like wow this this person has I
kind of impact on people where they just
love him that much did they come support
him before his fights I thought it was
amazing now you yourself you run one of
the most successful martial arts schools
give us a few tips on running a
successful martial arts school well I
mean you know basically it's as friendly
you know friendly happy students happy
life you know keep your students happy
keep them knowledgable people keep keep
them in you know motivated you know and
you'll have a successful jump you know
you don't do that you know and you got
problems so we talked about a few of the
tips that are very important what about
over the years we all make mistakes and
they they say that you know how did a
wise man become so wise and then they
asked him he said I learned from other
people's mistakes so Javier what are
some of the mistakes that you've learned
in training or in running a successful
school that you've made that if you can
go back that you would correct or you
would teach people these mistakes so
they don't make them
well the one big mistake I learned as a
coach is when you're the head guy you're
responsible for what goes on whether you
whether you acknowledge it or not and
for a while there years ago I used to be
kind of like just tell the truth and
accept etc you know and it made my guys
look bad because I was like having no
blame in any part of it which is wrong
because you know I saw what was going on
and if you're the head coach it's your
job to try to come in and correct the
situation that's bad so rather than you
know really fully commit to trying I
would try half-heartedly and then take
it okay well they're not going to change
instead of actually hammer it down it's
you know my responsibility to do these
things properly not half way to them and
I used to halfway do them and and now I
don't half way do anything tonight I go
full board on it and and if there's an
issue and the fighter and myself we have
to get in a heated conversation for even
a fist fight and then then that's what
will happen you know as long as we
straighten it out and fortunately for me
it's never happened where I have to
throw anything with anybody but I've
made a lot of mistakes and and you learn
from your mistakes and and the whole
idea has got to look to try to correct
your mistakes and and you know you got
to look at yourself too don't just look
at other people and say it's their fault
you know you know you gotta examine
yourself first before you make a final
decision did people call you coach
Javier what do you prefer to go by it
doesn't matter cuz I mean Javier Javy
coach I mean I mean I you know I know
what they're talking to so I I don't I
don't particularly care so d/c he just
won his his fight last week and he
sneaked right before the fight he
sneezes and in his back goes out what's
going through your mind well I wasn't
there so what was going through my mind
is nothing nothing about it but I'll
tell you what happened after so I guess
that happens to him but I go we're going
to the fight usually we all go together
that's the way it always works the UFC
picks you up
of us although the whole team that's
involved in a corner man and other
people so we're all basically on board
meeting at his room getting ready to go
and he says hey crazy Bob cook says to
me I'm sorry crazy Bob cook who was the
manager also and coach DC with me he
says hey just so you know DC threw his
back out sneezing this morning and my
mouth just dropped open like what the
hell and so you know he said that the
UFC doctor was working on for hours you
know and I guess he took a nap he woke
up at 5:00 and I guess from not being
able to move at all he was able to move
move and he felt like he was gonna be
okay
you know so I kind of was freaking out
in my mind thinking oh crap you know the
number one thing that we need to do with
this guy's Russell and the number one
thing that could be in jeopardy is his
wrestling ability if he's back really
goes out again and you know hopefully
and that didn't happen to us but had his
back darn out again oh my gosh we would
have had a hell of a time with with
Derek because the wrestling was the
reason why we were able to nullify him
beat him as easy as we did it wasn't
that it's not tough it's just his
wrestling wasn't to the ability of where
DC's at and we knew that Derek's never
felt the kind of pressure and wrestling
you know the DC was gonna give him at
what age do you start to see and all
your experience that guys kind of start
going people start going in Reverse I
call it you start you know the Machine
starts breaking down and it's really
hard you know because DC's 3980 is
better than ever
so I mean you're supposed to slow down
and he's getting injured but you know
he's better than he's ever been so you
know and I've seen other guys that 35 36
and they're in there they're not so I
guess on an average I guess 35 36 is
when you probably start seeing a little
bit but in MMA you know I think you find
more people past 36 that are still
competed at the highest level and
winning DC is one prime example of that
Jacare is another one you know for beach
forward them was another one you know so
a lot of these guys and em it may appear
to be able to compete
at the highest level at a later age like
wears in boxing they start falling off
you know I brought 3435 they start
falling off unlike you know someone like
Bernard Hopkins who you know was in his
late 40s is still whooping everybody's
butt so very rare in boxing seems to be
more common in MMA than the age they're
able to perform at a you know longer
piece what advice do you give for guys
to have better longevity and to be able
to last longer in martial arts basically
you listen to your body don't listen to
your coach your coach sometimes does not
know what your body knows if your body's
saying take a rest and your coach is
saying let's do this let's do that and
push it you know you really got to
listen to your body you know and if your
body says you need to rest
tell the coach and if he doesn't listen
to you then find another coach that's
some great great and great advice
tell us when you had all those going
back to the the moment when you had all
of those people in the blue shirts the
guys and I can see you're surprised look
have you ever had that many people come
into your academy to support one one
person to show that kind of love did you
did you ever experience something like
that when they came look with Habib this
is what happens okay this is very
typical average we get calls when he's
in camp I want to come down and see how
bean I just want to meet him for a
minute or even just take a picture with
him I'm willing to drive six hours you
know I'd get that all the time I'm
willing to drive six hours just to meet
him and they happen they do that all the
time they come in they wait outside and
if they take a picture with him and
they're going off and they're happy as
heck you know they're like oh my god I
can't believe I met him that type of
thing I had a one guy come he's a pilot
he came from Dubai flew all the way down
here went to San Francisco rented a car
comes all the way over here meets happy
for one minute gives a big you know
present and happy as hell that was his
you know just to meet him I've never had
that with any of my guys know me
remotely even close none of them he gets
more love
by himself than anybody I've ever all my
people that I've ever had all put
together and he still gets more love
than they all do it's unbelievable when
you go ahead and you see now being in a
sport for so long yourself also a
competitor how have you seen it come
when at one point did you see there was
more of the respect and the honor a lot
of those principles that were at one
point kind of get diminished and we saw
that in the Conor McGregor kabhi fight
or the great disrespect that was
happening do you saw as we started to
advance you know we kind of went into a
decay as far as that respect and the
honor that's come with the martial arts
it's kind of more people more concerned
about other things Fame and popularity
and kind of getting to a higher level by
being the most disrespectful saying the
most craziest outlandish things have you
seen a difference from when you were
fighting then and now no it's just this
is really just one person maybe two
people tops and you know he just happens
to be great at marketing himself and and
and the art of war you know he just does
that I just my feeling on that is that I
just wish he wouldn't say religion
family or politics just keep those
things out of it and you want to create
a buzz created but you're you're using
hate to create you know attention and
and I just think that you know at the
very least let the person know that you
know this is not the right thing to do
and if he chooses to do it then you
decide if you want to attach yourself to
that individual or not I I I never want
my guys to promote any of those three
and if they did I would talk to him
about him and if they choose to continue
to do it then I have a choice on whether
I want him with me or not and you know
I've never had that so I really can't
say what I would do because you know I'm
always on the fighter side good or bad
how they feel my fighters are all
different I treat them all different so
we don't all have one set standard
except for I just want my guys to be
good people but you know die you
I do let allow other people to do more
than others so it's not everybody falls
in line or I'm cutting you know they're
they're you know we have to have the
compassion to see things from their
perspective too we can't just listen to
our voices in our on our thoughts we
have to listen to their thoughts and
their voices to tell us your reaction
what also is going through your mind
Habib just wins the fight and you guys
are kind of at the after event at
someone's house and then he excuses
himself to go and pray can you tell us
about that that scene in that scenario
well you know here we go to a situation
where after the fight you know he does
what he does jumps the cage which he
should have never done nobody should
condone that and I'm sure you know it's
not something that he feels he should
have done it he knows he was wrong for
it but you know he also got pushed to
the buttons you know two months prior so
every day someone's pushing and pushing
and pushing your button then all of a
sudden you do something like that and
and obviously you know you know you know
it wasn't the right thing but you
couldn't help yourself we all been
through that especially when you
attacked those three items that I'm
mentioning so you know we go back he's
already got that in his mind you know
and then once he tells me he was sorry
he didn't mean to do it I apologized
said it's okay don't worry things will
be were things will work out and I so
something good usually comes out of
something bad you know and ten minutes
after I tell him that you know Putin
calls them you know and he's never
really spoken to Putin and gluten causes
them and congratulate him and and
basically just said he was proud of him
for how he stood up for his his family
his country and he was very proud of so
you know something that was created to
make hate out of a fight became more
unity in one sense so you used the bad
and made good out of it you know so so I
think that was pretty interesting and
from that point you know Habib has been
been meeting a lot of powerful people
presidents the king of Abu Dhabi you
know he's been on
on a worldwide type of you know kind of
traveling someone you know a lot a lot
of important people are I realized in
how special he is I mean he just got I
think he just got voted to the assistant
to the head of Dagestan he's the
assistant to that individual now it's on
it's on the news you can see it where it
says hobby was taken on as the assistant
or they offered it to him which is a
huge honor have you any plans or have
you have you ever been down to that part
of the world no I keep chickening out
and he you know he says I'm because I
tell him honey I never do but I'm but I
am planning on going I think January
this time around I am definitely gonna
go to Dagestan I don't know for two
weeks or a month I'm not sure yet
we'll see what happens but I'm
definitely going how important is it
nutrition into the into the the fighters
that you have the aspect of nutrition
into their regimen its key its key what
you put in is what you put out you know
thinking like anything right you know if
you're a race car you want to have
regular gassy when high-performance cast
right what's gonna get the best results
high performance right so it's the same
thing with your food if you have
athletes you have to treat it the same
in the people that don't the results are
in what they eat you know so you want
better performance
you got to find what's with what foods
are you know make you run better you
know and make you you know jump higher
stronger you know all those type of
things that are needed as an athlete it
was what you put in that comes out so
nutrition is is extremely important very
very important and a lot of these guys
are getting really good at nutrition
Habib's last two fights he'd he did he
did the training as far as nutrition on
his own you know he made weight on his
own and he was healthy strong you know
he learned how to eat how important it
is is it coach Javier Mendez now as I'm
also a teacher myself of the the martial
arts and I see this now the role
not only us teachers have but students
coming up how important do you think it
is now for people who have a bigger role
now they become UFC sensation stars that
sometimes they don't volunteer for that
role as role model but now to be good
examples for the kids for the future
generations by setting good examples
well I think it's extremely important if
you're in that position and then you
understand that if you don't understand
that you know you should try to at least
understand and they need to make the
wise choice on whether you want to be a
role model or not you don't have to be
you know it's your life you can do what
you want but if you care about the youth
of America and around the world that are
inspired by you then you would want to
try to be the best person you can be you
know but no one's forced to be anything
that they don't want to be you know the
whole idea is to expose you to the good
side of things and see if that's
something that is to your liking if it's
not you're not going to do it
you can't force anybody to be nice it's
either anymore it's not and if it's in
them bring it out you know and let them
let them experience you know what it
feels like to be a good person to help
others
what keeps you motivated all after all
these years what's the drive behind you
well my drivers love you know I look
forward to coming to the gym I don't I'm
not look like oh damn I gotta go train
so-and-so no I look forward to it you
know and I always tell my guys when they
have a meeting with me they're scheduled
to train with me if they don't show up I
just tell them look you're not gonna get
me upset ever upset if you don't show up
I'm at my gym anyway so I'll just do
something else so if you're not here
you're not here I go but you need to be
responsible because don't think that you
can continue to break dates with me and
I'm gonna still be here to train you if
you're responsible I'm responsible
you're not gonna show up let me know and
and it doesn't matter as long as you let
me know but if if you don't let me know
and you never show up and I'm here and
then then you know I'm gonna look at my
priorities and go hey you know what I
think I want to go eat with my friend
here I think I want to go somewhere else
so don't expect me to be here if you're
not here for me
and those are some of the principles
that really work really well and it
makes the fighter more response
and they know they're in control their
own destiny I'm not forcing it on them
they're doing it they're doing it for
themselves they're not doing it for me
they're doing it for themselves but they
know they have my support as long as
they do the right things do you think
Habib is gonna going to come back now to
to be in front of the Nevada Commission
there's some talk about him not coming
do you do you feel that is he gonna come
uh well you know I believe he will come
the only way he won't come and he
shouldn't come as if Connor doesn't come
why should he come you know don't give
an exception for one person and and the
other person doesn't I mean they're both
guilty you know once started it one
finished it but they're both guilty you
know
so they both need to answer to the
Commission they both need to be there
how did one person's team gets it the
other team should get it also you know
again they're both guilty you know you
can't you can't point the finger of
somebody and look at that you didn't do
anything that both of them did something
they shouldn't have done now granted you
can understand why Habib did what he did
but it still it still was not the right
thing to do because you're in a position
where the public could have got hurt you
know and you don't want to be in that
position even though most people would
have attacked him way way way before her
he did he held it longer than I think
any human being could possibly hold it
but regardless it's still not the right
thing to do yeah we're not condoning the
jumping over the fence but when you put
things in perspective now just being
fair and balanced can you fill us in
because people make the example of
others who jumped over the fence
was there any fines or is there any
suspension or other jumped over the same
fence for what I know you know there's
been you sees but you know all different
states now that is pretty tough on that
you know when Mike Tyson did with his
disturbance it cost him three million
dollars you know so it just depends you
know as the commission has never been
someone that's been fair I mean look at
how the guys say it's Nick Diaz yeah if
you think they've been fair then just
look up Nick Diaz and what they've done
to him in the past you know so they're
the most powerful organization in the
fight
world you know and you know whether you
like it or not you either bat with them
or you don't bat in the in the in the
prize world you know you just don't it's
impossible to without them you really
don't have a career in and and this
sport or this prizefighter that we do
you know so right or wrong there's still
the law for what we do what's the
maximum minimum that a person that he
can end up getting fined or suspended
it's hard to say and that's why I
brought out Nick Diaz because you know
for offense the cannabis that he was I
guess three times three or four times he
was you know a defender of that and the
minimum supposed to be two years they
gave him five or six I think four or
five years which is not what they're
supposed to do so for me to tell you oh
this is what's going on I don't really
know I know anything is possible I mean
I know that realistically I mean they
both they both shouldn't get much much
much of a fine I think they you know I
think that they basically should get
three to four months and and some money
but I don't think you should take their
whole livelihood type money from them
and and just to try to make an example
of them they were wrong both or more
wrong you know but I don't think the
Commission should come too harsh on on
on on Habeeb especially hobby because he
didn't he didn't start the talking you
know and and I like to see anybody get
put in his situation being a fighter and
having the the beliefs he does his
religion beliefs and as strong as he is
there you know and as much as him and
his father are connected and continue to
continuously having someone badger your
father man look I don't care about
religion for me you can talk about
religion all you want about my religion
I could care less it doesn't affect me
politics same thing for him I'll three
affect him but his father is so
important to him and we call him his
father a rat you know a terrorist you
know I mean all those type of things
that man if anybody knows how behaved
his relationship with his father is so
crucial and important you know that you
know and you would imagine that the kind
of love yes
his father just the fact that you
mentioned his father one time would make
anybody want to come after you
especially now we're seeing that the the
rise of Islamophobia is it's gotten to
the most it's ever been and I heard also
there's reports that the person that was
in the crowd he called him a Muslim rat
we know what was said we've talked to
people who were 6 feet from Dylan when
he screamed you blank Muslim rat and
that was the last straw and they had
been taunting this guy for weeks
insulting his family insulting his
religion his God his father
and others and at a point you know this
calm guy could be snapped
you know after winning the fight the
adrenaline is going high and the last
straw you blank Muslim rat is what Dylan
screamed so then what do you do to
khabib it was wrong I mean it was wrong
to jump the fence but you have to look
at what happened to Conor McGregor when
he ambushed a UFC bus and took a dolly
and threw it through a window and
injured four UFC fighters and really all
over to be and yet he gets arrested for
a felony he pleads to a misdemeanor no
jail time he doesn't get suspended
doesn't get fined yeah he gets suspended
by the New York Commission Athletic
Commission but he can fight anywhere
else
so now khabib is looking at possibly
having his entire two million dollar
paycheck withheld he is looking at a
suspension and God knows what else
there's no equivalency here and it was
wrong what could be did but at the same
time when you start taunting people with
racist crap over and over and over and
they finally snap and get the reaction
you were looking for all along what do
you expect from a human being is that is
that right something like that
I heard rumored that that there was
talks from different multiple sources
that said that there was talks being
said to him about that yes I
I heard those rumors firsthand I didn't
hear any of it but I've heard from
multiple sources that he was heckling
him throughout the whole thing so yes I
heard that yeah all of us I mean we
should respect each other this is
something like like you said I'm in
driving force you said that love and we
should have that love and respect
towards each other and I think those
lines you know we're definitely crossed
but tell us what have you observed now
being around him and being around his
brothers and the whole entourage you
know because there's a lot of hype out
there and you know misconceptions about
Muslims you actually having them around
you and some of its noticing some of the
behaviors like what is your impression
well they're very disciplined they're
very humble they're they they stay true
to - to what they what they what they do
but that one exception that I don't know
if it's within their their their code
but they they stick with each other you
hurt one you hurt the other if you do it
you do wrong to one you got to do wrong
to all of them
the their their their like legit family
you know you you can't you can't you
know come at one and expect the other
students to stand there and you do wrong
to one of their it just doesn't happen
they stick together that's why I like
how bu st. you know if you're not gonna
punish the other guys and just punish my
guys then tear up my contract because
you'll never see me fight again and he's
not lying you know he's like hey you
know fair's fair treat us fair we're all
guilty then give us all the same kind of
punishment but don't think you can give
me special privileges and you condemn my
guys who were really not involved other
than trying to help me mm-hmm
and I see his I see his point 100% you
know and that's what you're supposed to
do you know you're supposed to stand up
you're supposed to stick up for people
that are there to help you and and and
then and then reference Connor did the
same thing you know Connor didn't know
what was going on the fence was jumped
you know his cousin was up on the fence
Connor was up on the fence
Connors already thinking how he is ready
potentially doing what hurt and my guy
so he sees Habib's cousin so Connor
takes a swing and hits him and things
escalate you know not saying that
the Conor was right into his do you know
I'm not saying that he was wrong but
well so is javi for jumping the fence so
I'm just saying they're all wrong you
know and and it all started because of
the discussion of the politics the
discussion of the religion discussion of
the family have those topics been
avoided you know it would have never
happened just as much as had I been able
to foresee what was gonna happen I would
have told him you know to focus on on
being cool after the fight because I was
working with him
once we knew the fight was signed I said
look listen he's a master at the water
war he's gonna come at you religion
family politics he's gonna say all these
bad things I need you to stay in control
and I told hubby you either fight back
but if you fight back you fight back in
a fun way or you do nothing and you know
we were gonna do a scenario where he
first came out and I wanted to put
somebody a chicken outfit you know and
have Habib chase him down you know in a
fun way you know and have you said no
coach I please just please I don't want
to do that III don't want to come back
at him like that I said okay
respectful so don't go at him in a mean
way then and he did it he didn't but
what I didn't think about is what to do
after so every day we were talking about
stay humble stay relaxed use all this
energy against him to benefit you in
when it counts in the cage because
that's when it counts this is this is
not real life for death this is a
competition so you got to learn to win
in that that you know in that arena so I
work with him on that but I never said
anything about once you beat him you
know then be professional say this
because I think had I done that I think
we might not have seen what happened so
I kind of blame myself for not thinking
about that and also instead of going in
the cage right away like some of the
other guys did I went on the outside
like celebrating with friends like hey
high five type thing and you know I
should have went in the cage first
because I had a God in the cage like I
should have it would have never happened
because I could have stopped him you
know I could have stopped him and
so I'm partly to blame on that - even
though you're saying well what's not
your fault what kinda is because if I'd
have stepped in there I know the kind of
you know what I mean to him and respect
factors so I know that if I'm there if
his father would have been there it
would have never happened
that's deep I like what you said so I
mean it's always a learning experience
and you're evaluating it from every
every aspect let's have a few before we
cut out just a few more couple more
questions we'll make this we'll call it
the Xavier Mendes quiz since you're
around most of the fighters from you
here Habib's say certain words I made up
I dedicated to help people understand
some of the the common things that
you'll hear him say I want to know you
you spend a lot of time with him spend
years now right
since 2012 it was with me yo second UFC
fight on up to everyone after that yeah
so some of these words I give you let's
see how good you do with the quiz you
probably heard this bad have some fun
huh
I will start with this I'll say it
khabib says it I'll say and then you
give me let's see how good they are
we're not going to blame you we're gonna
blame them for not teaching you some of
the what the meanings behind these words
because it's so important assalamo
alaikum
a Salaam alaikum you have you heard that
before
Suman how you doing you know no problem
beep you got to do some work here you
okay
assalamualaikum how's that that means
peace be with you
peace be with you like I told you I'm
not religious yeah I believe in God yeah
and I just believe in being good you
know and I know God gives us the
intelligence to know what good from bad
is do I blast man you'll see oh you see
so if someone's saying how do you say
let's say how do you say yes you know
Paquito I love you how do you say I love
you maybe they amo te amo you let's say
you hear you keep someone keeps telling
you at the amo te amo and you're like
what does that mean but then finally
your wife
she tells you in English you can
understand the language you understand
now you're like wow that really you know
so I think it's important these words
there's so important let's get to more
we'll have some fun with Xavier you hear
remote no no you hear I'm always after
the fight you hear Habib say
alhamdulillah if I wanna sell
hamdulillah with ours God we cannot do
nothing everything is nothing you know
number one believe one you want God you
got that one okay okay Habib Habib
come on Habib it means all thanks is to
the Creator that's it that's kind of
like that's it's kind of like hallelujah
that's what it's like it's kind of like
okay well don't worry we'll get one more
this one will send some people in a
frenzy but when you know the meaning
again you had those hundred people chat
chatting it they were saying took be it
allahu akbar not at what i saw i saw the
expression on your face
god is great yes you got it okay we give
it to you there now that's it you got
how was that i wasn't too bad if if
habib if he gave you you seen him he's
been all over now he's travelling all
over but if he invited you from Dagestan
to go to to to Hajj with him would you
would you mind going it's the easiest
visa you can get what is that you gotta
just you gotta learn the Shahada that's
it make the show I'm gonna leave that
for Habib you gotta ask them what's the
Shahada Shahada that's the easy you know
every country you go to you need a visa
I'm telling you it's the easiest visa to
get it comes from the heart then it
comes to the lips it says Shahada I'm
not gonna let you know what it is but I
want Habib
I want have even if you do your homework
the Shahada and maybe you go with him -
you've seen because he's visited Mecca
and does the Hajj of Utah once he's
visited there a few times maybe if he
invited you in vitam habib if you're
tuning in so your coach they'll be a
wonderful
it's one of the best gifts he can give
you okay yeah are you are you planning
to be in the Midwest anytime soon well
Olli Habib's manager asked me if I if I
was available to go to Morocco Oh
Morocco beautiful yeah he was doing
something in Morocco or or he's going to
Morocco but he's gonna do something good
for people right they're doing something
some kind of donation either I read it I
read on online there was a million
dollar she's donating a million dollars
for some I don't think it's Morocco
something related to helping
underprivileged countries oh ok
beautiful beautiful you got a friend or
brother here in Chicago if you want to
stop in and say hello we're here thank
you so my really appreciate you taking
the time to us here on the dais with me
thank you god bless you thank you again
have your Mendes for being with us here
in the deanship I really appreciate you
for that and we left the homework for
Habib to go ahead and opening to share
what the Shahada is and insha'Allah you
can go ahead and explain that to our
friend Javier Mendez for those who are
too excited to wait I actually did a
program on the Shahada when Sinead
O'Connor took hers and I'll leave that
in the link below you can go ahead and
watch that so you can have a further
clarification and a better understanding
and if you want some more information on
some of those words that we tested we
did the fun quiz with Javier Mendez with
you can go ahead and I'll leave that in
the link below on those words where you
hear our brother Habib saying them quite
often again thank you guys and in
closing you guys are probably wondering
where's hubby why hasn't hubby been on
the Dean show yet well you guys keep
making do I keep sharing keep getting
the message to him and inshallah we'll
do our part and when the law is with you
when the creators with you has nobody
that can stop you if it's meant to
happen it's going to happen and
inshallah until then
you guys still stay connected to God
stay connected to prayer keep it humble
keep it respectful and to our brother
hubby send me the location let's make it
happen
send me the location my brother until
next time peace be with you a Sanaa
Malik
you